Diana recounts the ancient war against
Darkseid and we get to see this it
includes the Greek gods of Zeus and
Artemis and ares you actually see David
Lewis's likeness returning from the
first Wonder Woman the amazonians are
led by hippolyta and Robin Wright coming
back as antiope the atlanteans over ivia
ship and joining them is a Green Lantern
this kind of looks like yellinger Green
Lantern and this opening shot shows Zeus
handing Aries the battle ax that he will
later use to deliver the final blow to
Darkseid in darkseid's right shoulder
the same shoulder Superman cuts into on
Steppenwolf with his heat vision later
Barry Allen saves Iris West from a crash
including a gardener Fox truck a
reference to Gardner Fox Comics writer
and co-creator of The Flash Barry later
tells Bruce he feels lonely and needs
friends and this quiet moment with Iris
reveals just how his super speed creates
his barrier between him and the rest of
the world
foreign